Hales gum roses beautiful today we're
playing Adam Sandler wait what today
we're playing Adam Sandler dating
simulator because let's play new game
please Adam hey are you a new student
here - I'm Adam it's nice to meet you
I like the enemy hey Oh God come on
let's go inside yeah dude this could
probably be the greatest story ever told
check out these losers who said you
could come to our school
oh my god it's David who do you think
you I am Adam who are you I'm David
Spade [ __ ] you I'm gonna kick your asses
you can no I'm glad we got away from
them before they could beat us up
yes I'm so thrilled to be meeting you
Adam I guess so no thank you
no thanks to you about hole I'm so
thrilled to meet Adam thank you you're
too kind
thank God is lunchtime I'm starving for
buds law poop but what the [ __ ] I got
it's David's pity goddammit
I'm gonna beat your Sandler ass Yipes uh
[ __ ] you oh damn that's a cool face want
a date uh you got David Spade ending
[ __ ] you what what the [ __ ] was that I
don't want a David Spade ending not got
ya all right what if he click I guess so
no thanks to you butthole butthole
butthole
you got the bud tote and yeah good job
vato
why is there load game why why how
there's no saving this odd cat huh David
Spade you are going down oh damn you're
pretty buff okay okay I'll leave Sandman
alone please don't hurt me thanks for
saving me how will I ever make it up to
you I know I'll buy you milkshake after
school alright uh
Q thanks again for saving me from a
David Spade what about huh you're so
kind I know we only met today but I
wanted to ask you do you want to go out
sometime
we're out now but [ __ ] you of course you
got the ending where you date Adam Sam
I'm not sure that's a good thing
congratulations on winning Adam
Sandler's twisted heart you monster
oh my god so good so [ __ ] god okay
let's do [ __ ] you again goddammit I got
the butthole ending okay what if we say
no [ __ ] you [ __ ] you you pissed off Adam
Sandler that's probably better than
dating Adam Seth
good job oh my god best game ever I
would probably rate a 10 out of 10
thank you